اه واضح انه وزير الخارجيه لازم الاسرائيل
لازم نحطه في قائمه اذكى اذكى الاغبياء في
العالم يعني انا متفاجئ ان وزير خارجيه
يقول هذا
الكلام لكن
بصراحه يمكن ان تنفذ هذه الفكره له ومثاله
من المستوطنين
اي ان تبنى لهم جزيره صناعيه طالما انه
مبدع بمثل هذه الافكار فلتب جزيره صناعيه
له لامثاله المستوطنين الحقيقه هذا المنطق
هو منطق الذي لا يعرف قيمه للارض ولا
للوطن هذا منطق الذي لا وطن له وهذا يؤكد
بوضوح ان هؤلاء الذين جاؤوا الى ارض
فلسطين لا ينتمون الى هذه الارض ولا
يعرفون قيمتها ولذلك يفكرون بما تختلج به
نفوسهم ان يبنى لهم وطن وهمي جزيره صناعيه
في المحيط هنا او هناك انا اعتقد ممكن
ينفذوا هي ال الجزيره الاوروبيين وخليه
يحمل لقب بن جوريون الثاني في اعاده تاسيس
اسرائيل جزيره في وسط المحيط اما شعبنا
فهو لن يرحل عن ارضه شعبنا هو صاحب هذه
الارض هو صاحبها منذ الاف السنين شعبنا
عاش على هذه الارض منذ ان عرفت البشريه
الحضاره وشعبنا سيظل صامد في هذه الارض
سيحرر هذه الارض التي مر عليها غزاه على
مر القرون ذهب الغزاه وبقي شعبنا سيبقى
هذا الشعب ويعيد بناء وطنه من جديد ليكون
نموذجا باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى